Since 2021, Africa has experienced 13
military coups and coup attempts.
All but one happened in the Sahel in West
Africa, predominantly
former French colonies.
That concentration demands explanation.
Most global terrorism no longer centers
in Afghanistan or Iraq.
It's concentrated in
Africa's Sahel region.
Mali, Niger, Burkina Faso.
The same countries
experiencing this coup wave.
Political scientists have started calling
these events coupvolutions.
Coups driven by popular protests rather
than elite power struggles.
Today I'm examining three myths that
obscure what's
actually driving this crisis.
Not to pick sides, but
to understand the pattern.
Here's the standard narrative.
French colonial rule,
despite its problems,
built infrastructure and institutions
that benefited African development.
France's continued involvement maintains
that constructive relationship.
Let me show you what happened when one
country tested that narrative.
In 1958, French colonies faced a choice.
Join the new French community or vote for
immediate independence.
Only Guinea under Sékou Touré voted no.
France's response was immediate.
They withdrew military support,
administrative staff, infrastructure,
telephones, light
bulbs, medical supplies.
But declassified documents reveal
something more calculated.
French intelligence
launched Operation Persil.
They used government
printing presses to mass produce
counterfeit Guinean currency and flood
Guinea's economy with fake money.
Maurice Robert, who directed this
operation, later described it.
The operation was a total success.
Guinea's economy, already very weak,
never fully recovered.
Now, Robert claimed this wasn't
punishment for
Guinea's independence vote.
He said it was necessary Cold War
strategy, preventing the Soviet bloc,
which was interested in
Guinea's mineral resources,
from gaining a bridgehead
for the spread of subversion.
But here's what matters.
Whatever the stated motive, the effect
was economic collapse.
Currency depreciation, soaring prices.
And French Prime Minister Georges
Pompidou used Guinea
as an explicit warning
to other African countries considering
leaving the French monetary system.
Let the experience of
Sékou Touré take its course.
Many Africans are beginning to realize
that Guinea's policy is suicidal
and contrary to the interests of Africa.
That brings us to the system that
replaced direct colonial control.
The CFA franc.
14 African countries
still use this currency today.
Communauté Financière Africaine.
African financial community.
These countries must deposit substantial
portions of their
foreign exchange reserves
with the French treasury, a requirement
that continues for
central African nations.
France effectively controls monetary
policy for these countries,
setting interest rates, managing
reserves, maintaining fixed exchange
rates with the euro.
Now, the system has defenders.
President Alassane Ouattara of Cote
d'Ivoire, former governor
of the regional central bank,
argues CFA countries are better off than
Anglophone countries
because of this stability.
He points to inflation rates.
Cote d'Ivoire averaged 6% inflation
compared to Ghana's 29%.
Ouattara claims the CFA franc has
fostered the most
continuous growth in the long term.
French officials echo this.
Economic minister Michel Sappin described
the arrangement as
France acting in a completely
disinterested manner out of pure
friendship, guaranteeing unlimited
convertibility to prevent
currency collapse.
But critics, including a growing number
of African economists,
argue those benefits
mask structural problems.
The fixed exchange rate creates what they
call low competitiveness.
It makes African exports more expensive
while making imports from Europe cheaper.
That undermines local
manufacturing and agriculture.
And the resource extraction patterns
reveal whose interests
the system prioritizes.
Niger's uranium, for example, provides
significant fuel for
France's nuclear reactors,
which generates 75% of
France's electricity.
Yet Niger's royalties remain notably
lower than what the same French companies
pay in other uranium-producing countries.
A 2019 Afrobarometer poll found that
Togolese citizens were overwhelmingly in
favor of leaving the CFA franc,
reflecting a widespread belief that the
currency primarily
serves French interests
rather than African development.
So the question isn't whether the CFA
franc provides some stability.
It does.
But the question is
stability for whom and at what cost?
The second myth, French military
operations in Mali serve as
necessary stabilizing forces,
preventing terrorist
expansion and state collapse.
Let's examine the evidence.
In 2013, armed groups seized
towns across northern Mali.
France deployed Operation Serval.
5,000 troops, air support, advanced
military technology.
The mission?
Eliminate terrorist
threats and restore stability.
A decade later, Mali's prime minister
described the outcome.
Hundreds and hundreds of Malians have
been massacred over the years,
despite the presence
of over 50,000 soldiers.
By 2021, the region experienced over
2,500 violent incidents
and nearly 6,000 deaths.
Violence didn't just continue.
It spread from Mali into Niger and
Burkina Faso during
French military deployment.
Academic analysis concludes
the strategy was doomed to fail
because it prioritized killing militants
over addressing why
people join militant groups in
the first place.
Economic inequality,
governance failures, ethnic grievances,
French tactical
decisions made this worse.
To fight terrorist groups, French forces
collaborated with local militias.
Some committed atrocities against
civilian communities.
That drove civilians to join armed groups
for protection from the
very militias France supported.
Even French analysts recognized this.
Internal assessments noted that
unilateral interventions
fuel anti-French sentiment, undermining
France's regional influence.
So if French presence provided stability,
why did violence increase and spread?
And why did Mali's democratic government
collapse under military rule
while French forces remained deployed?
The evidence suggests the intervention
created conditions for the
instability it claimed to prevent.
Standard analysis treats each military
takeover as isolated domestic failure.
Corrupt officials, weak
institutions, poor leadership.
But watch the pattern.
Mali terminated defense
agreements with France,
expelled the French ambassador, demanded
withdrawal of French troops.
Burkina Faso did the same.
Then Niger.
All three suspended economic agreements
with Paris and shifted
towards Russia, Turkey or China.
That's not three isolated events.
That's coordination.
The military leaders explicitly used
anti-French sentiment
to justify their takeovers
and build popular support.
Research on these crews identifies
anti-French sentiment
as the fundamental factor contributing to
the recent spike in coup d'etat.
Finding that one of the main triggers for
opposition protests is
French presence in the country.
Now we need to be very clear about what
these military
governments have actually delivered.
In Mali, the pivot towards cooperation
with Russia's Wagner group has seen
increased violence against civilians and
little counterinsurgency impact.
In Burkina Faso, the convolution raises a
fundamental question.
Security analysts note it remains unclear
how, or if this can improve
the human security situation.
How likely is it that the same army, the
same military leadership
will be more successful
fighting armed groups now
than they were before the coup?
These military governments have
restricted press freedom,
postponed elections and
committed human rights violations.
They're pursuing power,
not purely liberation.
But their success reveals
something about French policy.
Looking at the broader pattern of the 23
successful coups in Africa since 2000,
16 occurred in former French colonies.
That's geographical concentration.
Roughly 70% of coups in
roughly 25% of African countries
indicate systematic problems, not random
governance failures.
In September 2023, these countries
formalized their resistance
through the alliance of Sahel states,
explicitly described as "against
neo-colonialism" and
"anti-French in outlook".
Mass protests
accompanied government positions.
Thousands in Niger marching
towards the French embassy.
Crowds in Burkina Faso
burning French flags.
Not government organized demonstrations.
Popular sentiment that French military
presence failed to provide security
while maintaining economic arrangements
that extracted wealth.
What connects these three myths?
Each obscures systematic patterns by
framing them as isolated
events or random chaos.
Economic arrangements get presented as
aid despite extraction.
Military intervention gets framed as
stabilization despite
increasing violence.
Coordinated resistance gets
dismissed as simple corruption.
France maintains its interventions
prevented complete jihadist takeover.
Possibly true.
Military governments manipulate
anti-French sentiment for legitimacy.
Definitely true.
Both points matter.
But neither addresses
the fundamental question.
Why do policies designed to help
consistently generate resistance?
The evidence suggests French involvement
systematically
prioritized external interests.
Resource access, migration control,
geopolitical influence over domestic
development in partner
countries.
Here's what makes it systematic.
Operation Persil
wasn't one bad decision.
In 1958, the CFA franc
arrangements continue today.
Military interventions from the 1960s
through 2023 followed similar patterns.
When policies fail for 60 years across
multiple countries, that's not accident.
The Sahel crisis isn't an anomaly
requiring external management.
It's the outcome of relationships never
designed to produce
genuine sovereignty or
self-sustaining development.
Whether these new military governments
will deliver better
results remain uncertain.
Early signs aren't promising.
Violence continues, democratic freedoms
contract, economic challenges persist.
But the pattern of resistance itself
reveals something important.
The relationship between France and its
former colonies faces a
legitimacy crisis that
military force and
economic leverage can't resolve.
The question isn't whether these
particular coup leaders deserve support.
It's whether we'll analyze African
politics through myths
that serve external interests,
or through understanding documented
patterns that drive
genuine political change.
Even when that change looks messy and
uncertain, because the
coup belt isn't random chaos.
It's the geography where post-colonial
arrangements are being rejected.
Violently,
imperfectly, but systematically.